[Music]
there's a raven flying for dragons
stormed out Maris's our only chance
ma there's another
kill him
he turned them all
you don't stop what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 Theory video today
I'm gonna be doing something a little
bit different
the theory I'm about to present to you
is not one that I created myself this
theory is actually from an article that
was written on blasting news.com and I
will put the link to the full article
down below in the description of this
video the person who wrote out this
theory is named Milos and he reached out
to me via email a couple of weeks ago he
told me that he was one of the authors
for blasting news.com and he said he was
a fan of my channel he'd actually
written a few things based on some of my
videos which I was honored to find out
Milo's also told me to check out the
website to see some of the other things
he had published and with his permission
he said I could talk about some of these
things in one of my videos so I went to
his page last night and I came across
this theory about the night king but I
thought was very interesting I cannot
recall ever hearing anything like this
before so I figured out what read this
to you then open it up for discussion
that way I can see what some other
people have to say about it the title of
this article alone had me very intrigued
it's called the night Kings biggest
secret exposed so without further ado
let's just begin the night Kings back
story will be the huge plot point of
Game of Thrones season 8 and his true
identity might just as well be the final
twist of the series after all the
showrunner has already confirmed there
would be three huge reveals that will
come straight out of George RR Martin's
pen first we had shereen's death she was
burn alive at the stake by Melisandre
with permission from her own parents
then an equally devastating hodor reveal
in season six episode 5 titled the door
which would have a horrifying connection
to Hodor his name so given the fact that
Game of Thrones is filled with our
breaking moments like these it's
extremely hard to pinpoint what the
final twist will be in our opinion it's
going to involve the night king so let's
find out how this might play out
the night Kings name may sound familiar
to some of you but the real question is
how George RR Martin's final twist could
involve the night king a character who
doesn't even appear in the Song of Ice
and Fire books
the answer is however simple just
because we haven't heard about the white
Walker leader in the books doesn't mean
he won't appear in the final two books
one of which is going to be called the
winds of winter there is also a certain
figure from the Age of Heroes whose name
is strikingly similar to that of the
night King we are of course talking
about the 13th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch who became the night's king
after he fell in love with a female
white Walker then he brought her to the
night for which is the oldest castle at
the wall and this is where he declared
himself the night's king and he bound
the Brothers of the Nights Watch to his
wealth through sorcery for 13 years they
would rule the night for together and
for that period they were making human
sacrifices to the White Walkers until
Brandon the breaker who was the king in
the north in German the
king-beyond-the-wall
joined forces to defeat him then all
records of the night's king were
destroyed and he was lost to history
so now nobody really knows who he really
was
but old man believes that he was the
brother of Brandon the breaker the king
in the north at the time which would
make the night's king a stark of
Winterfell it is our belief that the
white Walker leader we see in game of
Thrones is loosely based on this
legendary figure but before we delve
into all that let's go through
everything that happened during the long
night because only then will we be able
to explain who the show's night king
really is there was a very subtle detail
revealed when Jon and Daenerys were in
the cave together Game of Thrones season
seven featured an immensely important
scene in which John Snow showed Daenerys
Targaryen the ancient carvings and the
dragonglass cave on the island of
Dragonstone
it was here that we learned that the
first men and the children of the forest
fought together against their common
enemy the White Walkers this was also
something John Snow was trying to get
everyone to understand if they want a
chance to defeat the night king in his
army they will need to do it together
just like the children in the first
amended but there was however something
strange in the way the White Walkers
were depicted we saw three figures with
blue eyes with one of them wearing the
night king's crown but here's the thing
this white Walker has facial hair and he
looks nothing like the night king we see
in the show and just as a reminder take
a look at the scene for yourself the
enemy is real
it's always been real
[Music]
this subtle detail casts a new shadow on
the Westerosi legend of the long night
and the night Kings identity so here is
what we think happened during the first
long night according to the long night
legend azor Ahai called out his wife
Nissa Nissa and then he drove a sword
into her chest to forge the legendary
sword called light bringer it is our
belief that this was where Nissa Nissa
was actually turned into a white Walker
very similar to how the night king was
created in the show Nissa Nissa
sacrifice allowed azor Ahai to finally
forge the magical sword that he later
used to kill the first night king the
one with the goatee then Nissa Nissa and
the rest of the remaining white walkers
were banished into the lands of always
winter and the law was raised to prevent
any future invasions it makes sense that
some of the white walkers survived the
long night because they have obviously
returned since then this theory states
that after several years
Azure 'hi joined the Nights Watch to be
in the first line of battle should the
enemy dare to attack again and it wasn't
long until he was elected the 13th Lord
Commander Zhora hai fought bravely
against whatever was left of the white
Walker army until one day he spotted a
woman with pale skin that was cold as
ice and eyes like blue stars on the
other side of the wall according to our
theory this strange woman was none other
than Nissa Nissa in her white walker
form and given the fact that azor Ahai
was still madly in love with his wife he
couldn't resist her even though she was
no longer herself they made love
together and this is where he realized
that he wants to be with her again
no matter the cost that's why he was
turned into the noon night's king he
would then roll the wall alongside his
queen for thirteen years from the night
for the biggest night's watch castle and
together they were making constant
sacrifices to the White Walkers then the
king in the north and the
king-beyond-the-wall joined their forces
and they banished the night king to the
lands of always winter and captured his
queen so they can no longer make babies
together
she has been kept inside the crypts of
Winterfell ever since and she is being
protected by the dead kings of winter
the reason why they banished the night
king to the lands of always winter
instead of killing him is because he was
brothers with the king in the north
Brandon the breaker could not kill his
own brother although he hated what he
had become so now thousands of years
later the night King is out for revenge
with his great army and he is heading to
Winterfell to defeat the Starks and free
his beloved queen there is a section of
the crypts that is partially collapsed
and blocked off and this is most likely
where she is being kept
perhaps they were built over hot springs
to ensure it would never be cold enough
for her powers to reignite it is our
belief that the night Kings backstory
will be explored in a flashback right
before Jon Snow who is possibly as or
Ahai reborn kills him with the new light
bringer John will Forge this new magical
sword by stabbing Daenerys in the chest
thus turning her into a white Walker
that's how the story will come full
circle and a true george RR martin
fashion and only then we will be able to
realize that the villain is just the
hero of the other side I thought this
was a very interesting twist on some of
the already popular theories or legends
from this story I really like the
parallel between Nissa Nissa and how the
night king was created Nissa Nissa was
sacrificed by being stabbed through the
heart thus creating the legendary sword
Lightbringer and
King was created the same way by having
a magical weapon plunged into his heart
this is the first time I've ever heard
someone say Nissa Nissa was turned into
a white Walker after she was stabbed by
Lightbringer and she was the female
white Walker that joined forces with the
13th Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
who would later be known as the night's
king this would be a great final twist
in the show because all this time we
thought the first azor Ahai was a hero
but he ended up becoming a villain in
the end because he couldn't resist his
wife who he turned into a white Walker
after she had sacrificed herself for him
I'm not sure how everything lines up
with the timeline but this is just the
kind of twisted love story George R
Martin would write but who's to say if
any of this happened but I guess we will
just have to wait and see put all your
thoughts and questions down below
because I'm interested in hearing what
all of you have to say about this theory
I want to thank Milos for reaching out
to me and giving me his blessing on
talking about this on my channel and I
do want to apologize for how my voice
sounds today for the past two days I've
been completely losing my voice my
throat feels extremely raspy right now
but I'm trying to do my best I also want
to thank everyone for stopping by to
watch the video along with all of my
supporters on patreon I love you all and
I hope you have a great day I'll see you
soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]